you
[Music]
hi everybody I'd like to welcome you to
our talk that's kind of an interesting
hybrid of programming languages and
science which usually I would say the
two often don't go together but should
more often so andreas tefik is our
speaker he is from University of Nevada
Las Vegas and I first met him when he
was explaining statistics to a speaker
in a conference that was better than the
way that the speaker could explain her
own statistics and that was pretty nice
because address is really he feels very
strongly about doing methodology
properly he's a very proponent of
randomized controlled trials especially
when you're dealing with religious type
questions such as these things that will
show up in programming language design
lots of questions have been around since
like you know the beginning of
programming languages that are unsettled
still to this day Andreas has been doing
a lot of research and to try to figure
out how to answer those questions in a
scientific data-driven way so let me
hand it off to Andreas to tell us all
about that all right
thanks for inviting me Andy I appreciate
it and I have the distinct impression
I'm going to enjoy the dinner later as
well there's a home-cooked meal I've
been promised so I'm gonna help though
so as Andy said my name is Andy Stefan
I'm a I'm a computer scientist by trade
but I've spent quite a lot of time with
psychologists and people sort of in that
vein and I spent the last few years
especially sort of being especially
inspired by how other fields solve
really big problems that the fields have
and so I kind of want to start with this
story that was actually a very famous
test that happened in the early 1800s
and so sort of let me sort of set the
stage there was this doctor whose 1834
his name's Frederick Wilhelm von Hoeven
and at the time there were a variety of
medical doctors and practitioner that
were advancing this technique that they
called homeopathic medicine
right and that was the name it started
in the late 1700s by this guy named
Samuel Hahnemann and the idea was that
was called like cures like right it was
that if you have a subsidy if you have a
condition that's bad and you have a
substance like that then maybe that will
cure you right is that a good idea well
it didn't hold up to the evidence
however the problem is that there was no
way at the time to really know for sure
so van Hoven was really skeptical that
this might have been fraud or at least
he wrote a letter about it his letters
very famous called the van Hoven letter
right it went to a local newspaper from
a newspaper owner that was sort of anti
homeopathy if you will and it's very
hard to read it's in at the time in 1834
you can get the letter but the German
letters aren't the letters that they are
today so even though my colleagues and I
have expertise in German it's very
difficult to know exactly what he's
saying without someone expertise and
early 1800 dramatic languages but words
like charlatan and fraud are used quite
regularly in this letter right and what
this led to was actually a very famous
test called the nuremberg salt test and
it is widely regarded as the first what
is called randomized controlled trial
I'll get to this in a second but here's
the problem the problem was at the time
the doctors didn't really know how to
distinguish fact or belief from belief
or from fiction right they weren't sure
how to actually evaluate claims when
someone made them about a medical
practice or other things so for example
van Hoven when he put out his letter he
was challenged by homeopathy of the day
only Optus that we're getting money to
practice especially from the aristocracy
they were getting paid to do it so they
didn't want to give up their practice of
course right and they didn't trust each
other so van Hoven and his colleagues
which were also doctors they were saying
things like well we don't trust you so
if we give a treatment to patients we
don't necessarily trust them either so
we don't want them to know what they've
been treated with and the homeopathy
they're like well we don't trust you
either you're just going to cheat and
have this fraudulent procedure and then
your methodology will show that we're
bad even though we're
where were the good guys here and at the
same time since neither one of them
trusted each other they crafted these
procedures to sort of prevent fraud and
ironically even though they had fraud
prevention procedures in the test people
still committed fraud and they were able
to detect it using some sly techniques
there's early 1800s right so they
weren't very good tests but they were
orders of magnitude better than what
existed before and because they didn't
know whether homeopathy had an impact
they also had a non homeopathic
treatment and there's all sorts of tests
around the period some use things like
bread pills which is bred in a pill or
they used water stuff like that I know
shocking huh
but anyway as you can probably imagine
the theory of lectures like didn't
really stand up to the first experiment
a couple hundred years ago right and why
did they care about that there's really
good reasons medical doctors of the age
wanted more data is he's hardly the only
person of the age that was very
concerned there's the doctors that were
concerned about washing your hands
because they were showing it was killing
pregnant women there's all sorts of
horrible horrible things that actually
happened during the period in part
because there wasn't a lot of science
going on in terms of our medical
practices of that age and of course this
led to things like human death and
suffering and money going to the wrong
treatments and fraud being sort of
propagated as a as a methodology even
though it didn't work or at least belief
in something incorrect if not fraud so
interestingly although this was 1834
medical practices today still have
plenty of problems as I imagine many of
you probably know but there are
procedures now that are wildly wildly
beyond anything we see in a field like
computer science to detect fraud
especially today corporate fraud because
this has been a major issue for lots of
reasons I won't have time to go into but
there's registration of experiments
there's replication standards some
fields have they're required by law in
some cases so it's it's very complicated
and tricky but fascinating and
so well I'm starting with homeopathy the
reason for that is that even though this
talked about programming languages it
turns out that there are some parallels
between the evidentiary practices of the
early 1800s in medicine to the
evidentiary practices of computer
science today with notable exceptions
and we know that this matters
programming languages are sort of
foundational they're not the only thing
that matters there's all sorts of
conditions that are important like your
processes those can matter the
technologies are using the ideas that
you're using can matter there's all
sorts of factors and it's a very
complicated space just like it is in
other fields you know it's not like
medicine is simple right it's an
extraordinarily complicated search space
to try to navigate through and these
languages that we have even though it's
only one part of the problem it is an
important part of the problem for
reasons I'm going to get to so for
example one thing that you might think
about right off is how much actually
money do we pay software developers
right so it's kind of a hard question to
get at there isn't data from every
country but if you just look at the US
and you look at Bureau of Labor
Statistics data and then you look at
software engineers and people that sort
of support them so you can't really know
how many of them use languages and how
many don't but you can kind of get a
sense of how much it is and we peg that
from BLS data about three hundred and
thirty billion dollars right there's not
like a small amount of money it's very
expensive to pay a cell for engineers
and that makes sense software engineers
are highly professional people they do
hard jobs they work long hours it's a
tricky thing it's important and what
that means though is that given the size
of the industry even a small difference
in programming languages or productivity
by any metric can have a big impact at
scale even if you only consider our
country not necessarily others so let's
look at a case study from Google on
compiler errors just to get a sense so
as you know Google tracks everything and
one of those things in the subset of
everything happens to be compiler errors
of their employees and if you look at
that they published a paper a few years
ago on having tracked about twenty six
and a half million compiler
from software engineers using either C++
or Java right now if you look at the
data and we cut this up into various
ways to make certain assumptions that I
can get into later if you want but it
looks at Java developers had about 29%
point seven percent of the time they had
compiler errors right and for C++ it was
a little higher at thirty seven point
four percent right again these are
experienced software engineers working
in the industry at a major tech company
right yeah these are errors where the
compiler rejected it and so they come in
a variety of categories and they tried
to categorize them if you look on the
right on the graph these are the kinds
of categories that they gave but as you
can probably imagine sometimes it's a
little bit fuzzy if the compiler doesn't
know exactly what the problem was
but you know other is a pretty small
category and most of the time it was
things like dependencies and type
mismatch and stuff like that yeah no no
that's the point in fact it comes out to
be like 20 to 25 minutes or something of
a day so the point isn't so much that
that's that's not a hundred percent of
their day that's 100 cent of time right
I think is what their graph means so so
if we made an assumption that this was
an eight-hour workday which is probably
not fair right because people are gonna
vary and stuff like that but if we made
that assumption for the sake of argument
then we could and we assume that
Google's that is accurate and honest and
all that kind of stuff is well then this
comes out to be about five point nine
billion dollars for Java at scale at
about four point four eight for C++
right now there's lots of assumptions
there we can't say that that happens at
scale because we don't know but
nonetheless at least at Google it's
enough of money during the day that it's
a non-trivial amount of cash yeah
because the cows anything or they didn't
say anything about what actually is
going to happen to that 25 minutes mm
maybe the programmers just go home
earlier everyday doesn't necessarily
translate into actual money I would
agree with that yeah we don't know that
for sure you're right okay oh I'm sorry
yes I apologize yes this is okay so they
broken into two categories one of the
categories was time and I gave you those
numbers for just that piece and then
this is the percentage of build errors
in terms of like how many were they in
these categories thank you you're right
that's exactly what it's pointing out
okay in addition as it turns out besides
industry education in the United States
at least and not just the United States
but a bunch of countries are investing
quite a bit in computer science for K
through 12 this isn't just industry this
isn't just government it's a little bit
of both so if you look at expenditures
from this report called the BNY Mellon
report it doesn't look like that much
it's like twelve or thirteen million
dollars across the states over the last
two years
not exactly a lot of cash even the
amount that Microsoft I don't remember
the exact numbers is given to co.org
significantly Dwarfs this overall for
all 50 states new york city gave eighty
million dollars over ten year period and
the obama administration before it left
pegged it if I recall around four
billion as what is necessary to really
do it right now does that mean that that
will happen I don't know but the point
is that there's quite a few government
and industry groups interested in having
computer science lower in part because
BLS data suggests that industry needs
more software engineers right it's a
major problem that you can look up very
easily for that sort of stuff however
the thing is that's funny is that in
order to teach computer science at that
level you have to teach it in something
right so it has to be in a programming
language unless you simply choose to do
all like you know hand gestures or
something right or just conceptually you
could do that and it turns out there's
two major initiatives one of them is
called exploring computer science this
is an approach that was put out
originally
Margolis out of UCLA and it's a very
specific curriculum that has made
specific choices about what you do in
the classroom and it happens to be
polyglot
so it uses seven programming languages
so long as you define programming
language a little more broadly then to
incomplete so if you count HTML as a
language then that would be a language
if you don't then it would be a handful
right the point is as high school
curricula uses seven programming
languages for whatever reason I'm not
defending or refuting the decision I'm
saying that's a fact right and one
research team the United States picks it
for the whole United States like that's
that's how that works
the second option that some schools are
doing that's sort of up-and-coming
options is called computer science
principles and so in this particular
case students basically take a test and
if they do well they can get a little
bit of college credit for it no one
knows what college credit but it exists
this is programming language neutral
which has the opposite problem since
there's no one choice for language or
even seven choices that means individual
curriculum designers make their own
thing and as such a student in Alabama
might have a different conception of
what a loop is than someone in
Washington now again I'm not saying
that's good or bad I'm saying that
that's true right and these standards
are very different they're ratified by
the College Board so they've been vetted
by a great number of computer scientists
over a many year period and they're
pretty sensible I mean like they say you
should understand iteration and you
should understand you know conditionals
whatever and if you look in college
there's also no real consistent sort of
guidelines or standards so a few years
back we did an analysis of just 39
colleges in the Midwest and between them
they use C C++ Alice B B Python Java
c-sharp COBOL and ADA and if you talk to
these individuals
actually there's you'd be surprised
there's a whole bunch of universities
that use COBOL and it's for a really
good reason and one of them is because
during y2k they found that you were
statistically likely oh sorry
on average if you took a class on COBOL
during that period you on average got
$10,000 more on higher than you would
otherwise so
université it made a lot of sense in
that period to do that because of legacy
code so like I completely agree it's
insane but on the other hand like
alright well we'll get to that so yeah I
know yeah but in any case like I'm
absolutely not defending the use of
COBOL I'm just saying that when you go
talk to people that use particularly
ages they sort of fell into camps like
one group of people would say I use it
because that's what I'm told to use
right and then other people would say I
very strongly believe that this is the
right choice you know like the
individual whomever it may be that that
used ADA
I think there was only one school really
believed in that particular approach now
maybe he's right or she's right but you
know the data doesn't seem clear to me
so and as it happens these tools they
are they are dispersed they have
dispersion of designs right and it could
be that this doesn't matter or it could
be that it does but so for example one
language might say for left ran int I
equals 0 1 1 minus 10th 1 less than or
equal to ten semicolon I plus plus right
paren left brace system dot out dot
print line left paren double quote hello
- double quote plus I right paren
semicolon right brace you know rolls off
the tongue and another might say stuff
like repeat 10 times output hello stuff
like that I'm leaving stuff out but you
get the idea
just does show dispersion for trivial
choices but those languages actually
don't have a lot of dispersion for
concepts it wasn't like you were saying
Lisp and ml and you know past hours yeah
I think that's actually true so a lot of
languages they don't show dispersion for
what their goals are or what they're
trying to achieve they just they show
dispersion and the actual design to
achieve it yeah that's a good point it's
totally true
yeah and here's a good example so
generally speaking most languages have
this concept of string concatenation
right being Microsoft I'm going to go on
a limb and say I don't have to explain
that concept and if you look at the top
example which happens to be Java then
this concatenates if you look at the
example in the middle it happens to not
right now does it matter
either way what the choices maybe maybe
not you could debate it but at the end
of the day there's dispersion and in
that context that means that the design
leads to a different conclusion right it
doesn't do the same thing despite the
fact that we could agree or disagree on
whether a string concatenation should be
allowed on A+ in other words as computer
scientists we don't have much agreement
on even very trivial things very trivial
things and you might think that this
doesn't matter but in fact some types of
technologies the dispersion gets a
little wacky err so a good example is
the web when the web was being developed
you know it started with things like the
HTTP protocol in HTML and these sort of
technologies and over time we had
different needs you know we needed to
run it on a server all of a sudden and
have taken logins and we wanted to
manage formatting in an easier way so we
started making CSS and then someone was
like what I like CSS I need less or sass
or these other technologies and they're
different they're not compatible
necessarily right
typescript Dart I mean you name it right
on the server side it's the same
situation there's a great deal of
technologies and they do very similar or
the same things but they do it in a
different way there's dispersion that's
what I mean by that and the same other
database there's many variants of SQL
and no SQL stuff like that again this
isn't good or bad necessarily without
evidence to support it it's just true
right it's that this dispersion
exists right and this has side effects
potentially and they work in different
ways so let's take this y2k example
which I happen to have prepared ahead of
time and as it turns out during the late
1990s it's very difficult to get good
data on how much it cost to fix y2k
we've looked at a lot of sources on this
the best estimates we've seen so far
seem to peg it between 300 and 800
billion for the United States but we
don't know for sure how much it cost and
if nothing else it seems like it's
expensive
some countries track it better than
others some countries have their own
estimates and they have some evidence to
support them but it's tricky to find out
exactly but nonetheless it appears to
have been an expensive fix right and y2k
only comes around once but the problem
is as we progress as a discipline over
the next 40 or 50 years it's not like we
maintenance goes away so today we have
you might write your webpage with PHP
and HTML and CSS and SQL and whatever
right but in 40 years it could be that
someone has to maintain some of that
code some of it will die and some of it
will need to be maintained so the
question is which languages will live
and die what is the evidence for against
them and what's the cost of maintaining
a site built with end programming
languages
kappa learn a whole version is dr.
rachel average that's right and so the
question is what's that cost right
that's the question longitudinally
factored the benefit not just a constant
yeah I don't think we disagree I think
that like this is a cost benefit that's
exactly right but I my point is that we
don't have a good estimate of what those
are right so I don't think we disagree
at all so web maintenance where things
are changing in a very fluid and
constant fashion as an impact on the
issue of long term Safavid maintenance I
don't know it sounds plausible but I'm
not sure I don't know of any direct
evidence for against the hypothesis so
um there's one last issue I want to
mention with dispersion that I think
people don't think about that much and
that is accessibility technologies and
when you look at undergraduates in stem
about 11 percent of students have
documented disabilities this is a huge
range right like people on the autism
spectrum blind people deaf people you
name it right and as it happens some of
these technologies have real problems
because of dispersion and they're well
known in the accessibility community so
a good example is blind accessible
technologies if you want to make your
technology blind accessible and you're
using specifically Microsoft products
you're in good shape because you guys
actually did a great job and that is you
made accessible - which ended up being a
standard certain ways and other
platforms has all sorts of good
properties etc etc however if you want
your application to work on phones and
Mac and all sorts of stuff there are
different technologies they have to code
for they work differently and sometimes
they don't work at all so for example if
you have Oracle's accessibility
technology behind the scenes it is
mostly incompatible for screen reading
technologies it's okay it works
sometimes but not very well
so it's tricky the point is that
dispersion isn't just my plus operator
is different is that since there's
both a dispersion of the technologies
and a dispersion of the implementations
will you end up with his inconsistency
for different kinds of people like the
blind right see an idea but the problem
is this is one of those nasty problems
that we've talked about for a long time
in computer science this is not I'm not
really telling you something you don't
know necessarily we all know we have
different programming languages that we
have to pay developers money that's
clear and this is whilst of one of those
problems where one individual scholar or
industry professional or even CEO
probably can't fix it on their own it's
probably not possible so the question is
were there other fields in science that
had big problems and what did they do to
try to actually make progress on
problems that were bigger than
themselves how did we do that
and it turns out one of the most common
ways was number one getting more
evidence and trying to hammer it down
very quantitatively in addition in some
fields but not others
there were also political movements so
we'll talk about that a bit so one
interesting thing written by paper by u2
actually hey bro oh you wrote this to
your Devin boutot great I love this
paper so yeah that's true I do I really
like this paper so these three guys
right here happen to wrote this really
fantastic paper out of I think it was
Exede right but yes and they found
something I found really compelling I
know the idea you guys would be here so
this I didn't like plant this I promise
but it's okay if I did okay great
well the point is what they did is they
basically tried to figure out what
caused developers to believe things
right what did they believe and they
categorized it in a bunch of different
ways and they found and this relates to
previous social science research also
something I really appreciated about the
paper that things like personal
experience tend to be a little bit more
convincing to people than research
papers right and you know so things like
what I hear from my colleagues or peers
or managers we're a little bit ahead of
research papers and there's a couple
ways you can interpret this and you guys
were really cautious in your paper and I
will be a little bit less cautious right
one way that you could interpret this is
that social theory seems to indicate as
far as I can tell that you know personal
relationships matter and that's probably
true I don't really have any objections
to that however we might want to ask
what is in these research papers and
what is the evidence standard for these
things right
it's a Lisa question we can ask and we
might ask this because when we look at
people like language designers they make
a ton of testable claims right so for
example it's a little hard to see but
you might believe that ruby is AI
dynamic open-source programming language
to focus on simplicity and productivity
right that's what they say I'm not
saying it's true or false akka is a
library not a language but you can build
powerful concurrent and distributed
applications more easily right more
easily as a testable claim you have to
define it but it is something that could
be false and it could be true perl is
flexible and powerful cue for laughter
and the point is not so much that
language designers are right or wrong
it's that people clearly have beliefs
and there's also marketing claims right
so it's a complicated situation of
course you have note there's no problem
with saying I want to get my tools out
there and get them used that's totally
normal it's not a big deal but on the
other hand that's the job of the
business community the job of the
scholarly community is to figure out
what's true right to figure out
something is true or false and my job I
don't care about marketing I'm not I'm
an academic so my job is a little
different and as it turns out in
addition to the research papers
developers are somewhat skeptical of
research papers or at least it appears
so it's my impression from the data and
you can disagree if I got that wrong but
I don't think you yeah see ok there we
go
so educators as well people with direct
expertise in computer science education
actually don't understand the problems
their students have there's wonderful
wonderful paper that was just published
by brown and all Todd Murray he
collected a hundred million compiler
errors so I'm going to go out on a limb
and say that's a sufficient sample size
right and if you don't know any of deal
brown's work it's
amazing it's just absolutely fantastic
scholarly tour-de-force type stuff and
one of the things he did in his recent
paper was really made me laugh he
basically asked top conferences in
computer science education like icer but
also sort of like local UK teachers and
succeeds sort of like a group of
educators but not necessarily experts
like they might teach computer science
or do other things but in theory they at
least have some connection to students
but what he found is that you can look
at the data and there are weak
correlations but they're very weak right
basically if you actually track data and
then you go ask experts what they think
the the answer is they really have no
idea right or at least a very weak
association with the truth right and
this turns out there's at least some
evidence I think that this paper is far
less compelling in terms of its size of
its data but nonetheless it's an
interesting paper and I want to mention
it there's a there's a lot of work
that's gone in over the years on unified
modeling language or UML just show of
hands how many people use UML in here
every day
yeah your your this data that's 0 just
for all those watching on yield Internet
the data from Mary Ann Petri also shows
this it basically says we've spent a lot
of time in academia talking about the
details of these models and looking at
him and thinking about him and making
little theories about him and stuff like
that and nobody uses them right there
are a handful of developers in her
sample that did it a little but
generally speaking developers don't use
it that much groups I mean so you know
IBM's rational has a lot of customers
and they push this porch their lives in
your mouth yeah you and I are in total
agreement I mean like that's why I said
you know this is a sample size of 50
people that Mary and Petri went and
asked are those the right 50 people I
have no idea but nonetheless I think
it's at least a data point to consider
even if I don't have a better sample but
yeah you're completely right that's
that's totally true probably depends on
context and organization and stuff like
that yeah so okay
then we can ask the question is what is
actually in the
papers is there data in them right
that's a simple and reasonable question
did scholars people paid to find the
truth use the scientific method and
evidence and it turns out for
programming language data a few years
ago we ran a paper and we looked at
workshops so these are venues that are
not considered prestigious right they're
not the top venues they're just like
some places that claim that they gather
data on these issues there's three of
them one was called empirical studies on
programmers that no longer exists
there's another one called P Pig it's
out of the UK a lot of Cambridge people
were doing it for a long time and
there's another one called Pluto which I
actually participate in and I like but
nonetheless it's reasonable to ask what
the evidence standard is it's such a
venue and it turns out if you track the
data very carefully generally speaking
there wasn't really much evidence and
when I say very much if you read the
details of this you find that it's
astonishingly low like even simple
things like did they try to detect fraud
would not be included in Studies on that
now I thought I was crazy when we found
this because we ended up tracking a lot
more papers than it was in this we ended
up with about a data set of about 2,200
people I mean 2,200 papers and we
thought we were crazy because a lot of
the papers that were published at major
venues small venues that he's dedicated
to certain tasks weren't really using
evidence and so I thought that was
insane until this dissertation came out
by a guy named Antigua Hani Kijana ho
now let me set the stage for a second in
the Medical Sciences which is very
different than computer science between
1960 and 2000 the use of these sort of
fraud prevention procedures which were
developed for good reason increased past
1960 by 11.2% a year after this guy
named Austin Bradford Hill came into
play we won't go into the details
although they are insanely fascinating
he's the guy that figured out that
smoking causes lung cancer if you don't
know Bradford Hill um
increases it by 2500 percent if you
smoke a couple packs it you know a
couple of day anyway the point is
compared to those procedures they ended
up with something like a hundred and ten
thousand studies or somewhere in that
ballpark by the end of 2012 we had 22
right so this includes
top venues poeple oops la major academic
venues that are dedicated to programming
languages software engineering any topic
that you would think might be relevant
when we're talking about wages in the
size of three hundred and thirty billion
dollars in the United States right
twenty-two experiments now when I say
twenty two experiments I mean something
specific this is what Kijana Howe
considered to be randomized controlled
trials and that matters because these
are fraud prevention procedures these
are like you didn't try to cheat like
you had a control group like if you said
ruby was good you compared it to
something right and you didn't test
yourself you know just really really
basic stuff now you might think this
doesn't matter until you start looking
at some other data from antico who's at
the University of Washington if you
don't know they analyzed for major top
cop conferences or journals in software
engineering and they found something
also sort of odd on the one hand they
did find that 77% of papers do include
some kind of empirical evaluation rights
people are using some kind of data of
some kind however even though it's
software jeering and in theory that's
connected to like something related to
people building software only 27%
evaluated human use of a tool and of
those 62% of them tested themselves
right they said I have this great tool I
tested on me and it was kick-ass right
that sort of idea
now this isn't my data this is something
I've confirmed with Andy because I
didn't really believe it right that's
insane that's there's no way that should
be true there's no way that should make
it past peer review but 62% of the time
that's what happens yeah I have no idea
it's never been tested but I bet it'd be
better but I don't know to use human
studies and Morse
I guess methodology comes from
psychology than we do yeah I would bet
that that'd be true as well but I've
never seen like a meta-analysis on it so
are you going to take a position of
natural experiments you
you a sort of do you have a feeling of
what actually experiments are I'm happy
to talk about that and I know some of
you here and I'm a sari guy type that
kind of stuff too I love them I think
they're great I actually use your
research in my lab for generics because
it does it actually turns out ok so let
me explain this in the context of
medical history so in the 1940s this
hasn't found the slides but I know this
off top my head because I this is what I
like this is what I love in the 1940s
there was all the when people were
coming back from World War two there was
this huge opportunity in the medical
community because soldiers were coming
back and they had very serious problems
these problems were really serious to
the point where the nation got together
and said we have to make sure we're
doing for the best we can for the
soldiers as possible and the only way
they could get the kind of sample sizes
that people believed was through the VA
but there was a problem it turns out the
actual modern way of conducting
randomized controlled trials was only
conduct finished in 1935 with Ronald
Fisher's famous book on experimental
design which discussed like p-values and
all that kind of stuff and we all know
that there's problems here there were
that stuff but nonetheless in the 40s
what was happening is the VA started
doing sort of experiments and they
couldn't really do it at scale right
like they'd go to this one hospital and
the doctor would be like I don't believe
in control groups sorry and then you'd
go to this other hospital maybe yeah I'm
not use that methodology sorry and there
was other people by about 10 15 years
later that started doing very similar to
the national experiment you're talking
about like on github and stuff the
evidence center is much worse because
you know they can't pull down a repo
from good right ass lot easier but they
were doing natural experiments and at
the time these people hated each other
they were fighting and they were
fighting because the one group the
natural group was like the
epidemiologists well that's what they
called themselves to my knowledge and
then there was the other group which was
the we need to prevent fraud both had
totally legitimate concerns and so ended
up happening is this guy Austin Bradford
Hill said why don't we just do both and
see if they match right and so what
happened was they came up with this
concept called coherence mr. Bradford
hills like big big idea
fundamentally changed the world I don't
mean that like in a little way really
did and it led to what is now known as
the phase randomized controlled trial
medicine and eventually something called
consort which is a an evidence standard
to show replication of studies and to
diminish corporate fraud so the idea was
really simple it's like if there's
people gathering natural data why would
we possibly not want to take that into
account on the other hand since we know
that we can't control natural data we
should use experimentation at little
various scales and the phase randomized
control problem allows for small and big
ones to root out who the liars are right
so it's a little bit of both you use a
combination of metrics and you check
whether they agree or not and turns out
Christiane's data on generics matches
other scholars do in experimentation
it's true yeah it's not like you go find
people actually are actively doing
something in you know and totally change
their lives in medicine you know
hopefully not right yes they now have to
take a different pill different
treatments generally other months the
actual incremental cost to them is
actually very low whereas with
programming it's you can't learn I
believe you have to miss stuff you can't
learn something by some small experiment
I actually have to like get over the
whole hump of learning everything
becoming proficient and knowing how to
do things and spend you know weeks
months or even longer perhaps being
proficient before I can actually
understand whether I was really better
off so there's a lot of hurdles to doing
and then the other one is fry the nature
of fraud seems to be really different
marketing guys are also helpers
but there's a lot less fraud accountants
differently I think in the sense that I
actually can evaluate whether or not I
feel better off using something or
believing something somebody told me and
applying it so it's a real democratic
thing that takes place where with
medicine it's like I have no idea maybe
helps me maybe doesn't but the doctor
says it's statistics that's all beyond
me whereas programming each of us who
actually tries to go some path can
actually understand whether they think
it works or not so the ability to
actually commit fraud against me is a
lot harder because I figure out it's a
fraud myself hmm okay I actually really
appreciate that question I really mean
that because I think that this is
something that's really hard to
understand and that is that you know
when you're talking about people
committing fraud against you you're
definitely I assume and correct me if
I'm wrong you're talking about like
technical things like if I tell you go
use this algorithm it totally works you
can try it and if it's not true you can
test that that's really easy right try
to make is you email for five years hi I
believe I'm not surprised with that one
bit but what I'm talking about is
slightly different we're talking about
things that are kind of harder to
determine for an individual like I would
never tell you go use you am al right
that would never be in my lexicon but I
do think that there are questions where
you can look at this coherence aspect
where like what do we see from natural
experiments and what do we see from
experiments that are done at smaller
scale or at different levels of scale
and then we can ask do they agree and
that was the key with Bradford Hill it
wasn't saying we have to operationalize
this and now this drug is approved or
not that's like a government thing it
was saying if we collect any data that
we can find from anyone under any
possible set of conditions that we can
does it agree or not that's the
difference so it's more like a
questioning type of approach as opposed
to like you should go use a mile which I
don't really believe in either so does
that make sense
yeah yeah or or even when we go get new
stuff like does it agree or not like if
Christians data disagreed with these
other experiments it doesn't mean that
one of them is necessarily right it
could be that they both screwed up their
methodology in different ways right so
the BI sees that one might bring in all
honesty through natural experiment data
analysis is complementarily dealt with
by devices that might have pain in
control experiment design so I think
that was Bradford Hills of you okay okay
so but I want to end this talk by
talking about specifically experiments
I think there's wonderful wonderful
stuff out there that is on the natural
the natural side I just don't know it as
well right I know some of it but I know
the experiment side better and I want to
give you a sense of what it shows right
and again I'm not telling you go do this
for that I'm just telling you what is
the data show and on whom right so um
number one if we talk about students now
when I say this I always like to talk
about students and professionals a
really good reason for this
and that is because people program at
different periods of their life there
are students in K through 12 that are
learning programming in kindergarten so
it's completely reasonable to ask how
hard is it for a kindergartner on the
other hand and this is something Andy
said in one of his papers once actually
and he said but people in industry
actually invent the technologies that's
obviously true right like it seems like
Microsoft builds tools that get used by
people and if we don't take them into
account either
that seems spurious right why wouldn't
we just take both into account and then
look at what the data says as a whole
again it's coherence right this is this
idea and so one of the things that we
like to do on when we do student studies
is we like to sort of tease out what
things might be impacting them
positively or negative either on average
or for groups and you'll see that
grouping matters in this context so one
of the studies we did a few years ago
was on language notation or syntax right
now when I say syntax I use that term
loosely because computer scientists
often think about it like this is a
parser right this is not what I mean
what I mean is that different
programming languages have used
different notations to mean different
semantics and those can be done in
multiple ways does that matter
and it turns out one way that we did
that is at least at the time I grabbed
one particular language that we made
with rolling dice which we came up with
because of looking at Benjamin
Franklin's experiments from the late
1700s on mesmerism which was just
another fraud technique and so what we
did is I had my graduate student sit
around and like use a random number
generator and generate a programming
language totally randomly like the
symbols were like slash for this and
plus for that there's just random
symbols from the ASCII table and you had
to try to interpret that and we did that
because we were thinking that might give
us a baseline for languages like it
can't possibly be the case that
languages don't aren't at least as easy
to understand as one where we used a
random number generator so we called it
a placebo language right now let's
placebo the right word you can debate it
in the literature in the early 1700s
they called them sham treatments and so
whether you call it plus E Bo or a sham
is relevant but that's the idea it's
something we shouldn't see work right or
that you would expect people to do
poorly on and not surprisingly people do
very poorly when they're just starting
out with a language that is designed
randomly that's not that surprising what
was more surprising was that Perl and
Java didn't do any better and we know
why the reason why is because of
specific word choices that we were able
to pull out using a statistical
procedure called token actress mapping
and it's really simple it works like
this you basically take the examples
that people gave you and they have to be
small and there's some rules about it
and you have to use these particular
techniques to evaluate it and you have
to check reliability between independent
observers of these techniques and stuff
like that and that stuff has to be
hammered out incorrect to do it right
but if you do that you can actually see
the areas of a programming language that
novices did or did not do correctly and
it turns out a lot of the things we take
for granted like for in a loop mean
nothing to novices so for example use
the word repeat over for it triples
their accuracy on that token triple if
you use equals instead of double equals
and you overload it for both assignment
and equality which you think might be
bad I thought was bad
but it turns out it has no impact on
assignment and it gives you a increase
on the Equality symbol above Eightfold
inaccuracy and when you think about it
that kind of makes sense it's misleading
right to a novice that hasn't already
been trained right now you might also
think this is a small study this study
hat was replicated I don't know a bunch
of times and then we ended up publishing
two of those replications one of them
was small-scale with 18 people the other
had 60 something right same answer for
both right different samples all that
stuff but you might think if we did a
natural experiment like we look at Neil
Brown's data maybe we don't get the same
answer but we do in fact it turns out
the regions token accuracy mapping
predicts would be hard for novices are
exactly the same things we find in these
massive natural datasets we get the same
answer but and this is an important but
this is novices all right this doesn't
mean this will help you right not
necessarily so what we need to do is we
need to also ask questions that look at
different kinds of people so one of the
ones that we've kind of had fun getting
hate mail about is the static versus
dynamic typing debate right how many
build heard of this debate right just
you don't have to take a stand I'll give
you three possible positions position
one is I believe static position two is
I believe dynamic and position three is
either I don't know or maybe somewhere
in between so anyone for static anyone
for dynamic and anyone that wants to be
on the fence okay good so as it turns
out this is two particular papers I'm
going to show you a synopsis of a bunch
more one it's from XE if you look on
this pressure graph it's kind of hard to
see these are box bots so I don't really
want to explain all the details but at
the end of the day static typing allow
these individuals to write correct
programs defined operationally by the
paper more quickly right and we know why
and the reason why is because if
developers have dynamic typing what they
do when they want to use a function is
the go look for what they pass to the
function and if you videotape them and
you take out that time it matches
in other words if you have dynamic
typing and you want to use a function
you have to know what to pass to it and
we thought maybe we could throw that
effect away if we just put in the
documentation what you pass to it turns
out that doesn't work why I don't know
but that's the answer and then when you
look at these things one thing that
people are often concerned about with
experiments is replication and for good
reason because replication is hard and
unfortunately as well other disciplines
have things called evidence standards
and this is a technical term this is not
like something I'm making up evidence
standard is a formal document adopted by
a community that says you must follow
these particular standards a good
example would be if you have statistics
you must report the p-value and the
effect size would be a common example
right and that just says you don't get
published unless you have that right or
another one might be you must have a
control group right there's something
very simple you can decide as a
community for this particular venue or
this journal if you don't at least have
this fraud prevention procedure in place
you won't get published the most common
one in medicine is called consort and
this one was designed in part because of
all sorts of problems in the 60s but
also because of some famous court cases
in the early 2000 where corporations
were committing fraud that was murdering
people right which is not pleasant to
say but it's true so they have this
thing called registered randomized
control trials it's a fraud prevention
technique etcetera etc so we tried even
though I work in a discipline that has
no evidence standards for these things I
have evidence standards and so one thing
that we do is we replicate our
experiments in all sorts of different
ways so for example our statically typed
API is fast reuse this is two studies
mention the top the answer was yes they
have the same effect size effectively
same answer different people sometimes
different countries write is the
previous finding only a matter of syntax
turns out if you twiddle with the type
declarations to make them wrong then yes
it's misleading and that's that's what
happens right can documentation
compensate for the positive effect of
static types turns out the answer is no
it has a small impact but the effect
size is only 0.14 it's not that big of a
difference do generics help with SATA
typing turns out
but only in certain regions of the code
right so it turns out if you have
generics on method declarations that
tends to help but if you have to use and
write your own generics classes that
gets nasty right
what about IDE so some of the previous
studies were done in text editors only
it could be that just doing it a text
editor is the problem and if you just
had really good IDE support that that
would help turns out it doesn't same
effect size regardless of having a
really up-to-date IDE what about a
benefit for dynamic type systems if you
just to go totally nuts and you try to
design static typing where it's insane
you know like you just come up with the
craziest like examples where you have to
have triply nested generics with
question mark extends or some other
nasty stuff it turns out if you do that
there is a way to see a small benefit
from dynamic typing but it's so nice Oh
Tarek that it's hard to see most
developers actually doing that and
practice although you can verify that
with a natural experiment right in fact
you did which is why we did it that way
right and then finally this one isn't
published yet but if you some people
argue if only we had type inference
right a lot of work has gone it like
poeple places like that to do type
inferred type systems it could be that
that inference is what helps but
remember the theory here the theory is
that if you don't know what to pass
that's the cause of the time so we would
expect to see no effect and we don't
same answer right so we're talking maybe
ten to fifteen replications I forget how
many of those up my head now and that
data seems to match with people doing
natural experiments right so it's not
perfect but that's where it is so two
other examples just to give you a taste
right one is how many people sort of
aspect oriented programming right how do
you believe it's helpful how many
believe it's not and how many believe
that it's either unclear or you're not
sure okay so there isn't a lot of data
there's only a handful of experiments
but they seem to show it has no impact
like the types of things the guy that
made it well there's a few people when
they argue about it but one of the
people that did it was Gregor Cazalas
back in the day and they made arguments
saying basically that
help for certain kinds of code like
logging and stuff like that and you can
find some effects for logging that are
kind of small but almost nothing else
right so it could be that it's great for
logging but it just really isn't useful
otherwise and in fact the data shows us
the only one they've been able to
document is true and the effect size is
small for that effect as well
I forget which task it was in here
because one of these there's a teeny
teeny tiny effect and then the rest is
just in a wash so so your hunch is
what's supported by the data as well so
in any case not much in the way of
replications for that experiment but you
know you could try to invalidate them
through natural or experimentation
through coherence and the final one is
one that one of my students did I just
think it was fun we've heard for years
that lambdas were like the best thing in
the world from many people and so we
were curious right so we decided to test
just one thing cuz you can only test one
thing at a time
there's no replications on this to my
knowledge and I don't know of any
natural experiments maybe they're there
or maybe there's some pieces in a couple
papers here and there but like I said
it's not as much my area of expertise
and so what we did was we thought okay
maybe this is different across
experience levels maybe you have to be
really really experienced with lambdas
to use them correctly or maybe it's the
case that you know it'll be the same
you'll get this big effect across the
board we weren't sure so we tested
freshman in college sophomores and
College juniors in college and seniors
in college they learn lambdas somewhere
around their junior year or so so they
would have known something about them
and for the professionals that we used
we got people that were like serious
devs that knew something about
functional programming they were
self-proclaimed experts in functional
programming they know what lambdas are
so there's no debate right but when you
break down the data there was no impact
for the professionals they could solve
the tasks about the same amount of speed
is using an iterator in C++ right this
is just again one language I'm not
saying C++ has the best lambdas I think
they're kind of atrocious but that's not
the point
well no that's not fair they're not
atrocious they have particular syntactic
Bertie's that I think could be improved
there how's that well it's true I mean
like language design is hard and
sometimes when you're trying to be
general sometimes it's easy to get to
general or not general enough and that's
a difficult problem okay that's a great
question and the answer is you can't
write so this particular test only
compared two things and that's C++
lambdas of C++ iterators so we can't
necessarily say that this would be true
in Java other languages and some
languages have very different ways of
handling lambdas and in fact they use
them in different contexts right so like
for example the one area that if I was
to guess where lambdas could be really
helpful there's some really neat stuff
they do with lambdas in the JDK for
concurrency I have no idea if this would
be at validate in an experiment or not
but it wouldn't surprise me if there was
a benefit there that could be documented
possibly but I could be wrong I don't
really know because we haven't tested
that particular thing but in comparing
c++ two lambdas versus iterators we
found a very very strong negative impact
for people with less experience compared
to using a similar thing a similar thing
with iterators and for professionals we
found no positive impact right again it
doesn't mean you should or shouldn't use
lambdas it's nothing to do with that
what it means is that there was a
technical team of people that spent
years and years developing expect and
nobody did a test like maybe it's a
syntax problem and they should have
checked that or maybe like lambdas
really don't have a benefit that could
be the case right at least in one
particular language but these were added
all over Java C++ whatever scheme of
things they were right you have to
actually do it for the language develop
a robot professionals who
and corrects pretty using it and then
actually measure it and by that point
everybody's pretty much moved on except
for the guys who are kind of stuck in a
belief system and I believe it's part of
their world so I don't know what it
would be advocating practically for
applying we're saying sure I'm having an
answer that actually so what I'm
advocating for specifically I don't have
like a plan for action on the slides I'm
not trying to necessarily convince you
to go do something but what I would say
is that other scientific disciplines
break down big problems into manageable
chunks right so for example medicine we
have early experiments which are you
know either phase one or before that
where they're really really tightly
controlled and they try to come up with
a theory why something could be true but
we all know that just because you like
kill a bacteria in the lab doesn't mean
that you're not gonna kill the person
using it we all know that right well you
would agree right and with computer
science
it needs I think that one path forward
or beats using to do something similar
so like for example if you want to
change C++ for the whole world that
could impact a lot of developers then
there's a process you have to have some
low-level experiments that at least show
it's plausible and then if those work
out we need some natural experiments and
we need some experiments over here and
then if you go through this chain then
we say okay the evidence is sufficient
put it in C++ but it seems right now
that the process is just kind of like
people decide and they might or might
not do a good job by question what
nope but to mark impact one thing that
does see much might be some up here is
your programming languages to some like
that phonetics like you know far less
impactful than features in programs when
people develop programs they put
features like my favorite feature not
like is the ribbon and office you know
and I wonder did that really improve the
productivity of people who are using
office or not all the arguments and so
makes me wonder if you could actually
practically apply this in teaching a
software engineering course they
basically said here's a methodology you
can use compete with features into a
program you're developing for users you
know that would actually let you know
whether or not its features were a
benefit to them yeah in terms of
features I don't think we have any
disagreement there as well and you know
I actually do teach stuff like this in
my classes as well for for reasons like
that like for example in software
engineering I'm not talking about
programming languages but I do want them
to at least understand evidence for or
against procedures ma'am
world where people develop applications
actually yeah there's some speculation
and I don't know if it's true but it
would not surprise me
oftentimes in university education for
computer science i hypothesize but do
not claim to be correct that one of the
reasons why we've done such a poor job
and we have really done a terrible job
on using data and evidence for many
things is because we don't really
require any education on it right like
if you if you have if you work in some
scientific disciplines you have lab
hours right and you have to run
experiments on stuff and we do that with
programming like we're pretty good I
think as a community of like trying to
make something work you know hacking it
together and testing it running the
debugger or whatever you whatever your
methodology is but when it comes to
knowing these sort of bigger problems
that actually do impact a lot of you
know our productivity that impact you
know the tools we use not just the
languages but the tools and our
processes and all these things less so
right you know in any case language is
obviously complicated like
said this problem is much bigger than me
it's much bigger than all of us it's
much bigger than one company it's a hard
problem right there's a reason it's
persisted for a long time but it also
hasn't been studied very carefully like
there's not much data as I think is
clear from the evidence there are some
papers here and there that are making
some progress are trying to and we're
trying to start a community of people
that are doing this so for example we
have a slow Stockstill next year which
I'm sure a name I'm butchering which is
basically a group of academics coming
together to try to say we need to make
some progress and it needs to actually
use the scientific method so in any case
thanks for listening and I very much
appreciate all your questions thank you
so one comment so yeah so I think that
you know there the issue here is I think
it's a cultural one programming
languages people view programming as a
mathematical task like improving this
they're trying to prove something what
really matters is invitation on your
definitions and your rules of inference
things like that and whether or not
these notations are accessible to
hundreds of people of thousands of
people by the final feeling it's
irrelevant right and you know those of
us doing little work I think you know
software engineering side you know we're
sort of viewing programming as as a
human behavior to be studied as a human
being using experimental methods you
know so I think this these two
disciplines have very different
perspectives you know programming
language designers don't you know okay I
mean I'm generalizing a big here so
people who design language like Python
have a very different perspective but if
you're defending language designer names
like Haskell or JA you know typescript
and so on you're coming for very
different perspective which is what is
the right notation does it have the
right semantics and I prove the right
properties yep yes yeah you know if no
human ever use programming languages I
think that that perspective would be
valid right but you are right that's
absolutely what the what's going on is
that you know these trees they've
existed for a long time and they kind of
have their thing they do type soundness
proofs and they you know they twiddle
with some semantics and stuff and
there's nothing wrong with that that's
totally okay that's
yeah we have we have we have a diverse
group let's just say that yeah sure we
have people we got we're trying to get a
lot of people outside of computer
science as well people that understand
evidence standards in the stuff way but
well that I've tried to get one I don't
know if you'll go but in any case at
least some people that do there's other
evidence I'll get you in just a second
sorry there's people there's other
evidence standards besides the ones used
in medicine about evidence in medicine
uses Consort which is by far the most
rigorous of anything out there that I
know of for empiricism cuz you know if
you don't do it right you die right
that's kind of a big deal but other
communities have boom even moving either
adopting Consort wholesale or they
develop their own because of the law so
for example the in education they use
the what works Clearinghouse it's not as
rigorous but it has like prevention
standards and stuff like that so how
come all the languages everybody
actually uses that are really successful
in terms of broad communities or all so
actually the only paper I know of that
looked at the adoption in a really
rigorous way that I would consider as
scientific as we have right now is this
wonderful wonderful paper by Leo
Maravich it's this guy that graduated
from Berkeley a bunch of you know this
paper yeah graduate birthday bunch of
years ago and I forget the name of it
but psych empirical studies on language
adoption something happy to send it to
you
no no that's the early one the socio PLT
papers fantastic but the one that had
the biggest dents I think was he
improved Studies on language adoption or
something like that
socio PLT tried to come up with a theory
and the other one was like what actually
occurs both are good though but like the
socio peel T paper had this fascinating
observation that religious communities
that are hard to get into people tend to
stick with them does the right what I
was going to about to get to it could be
the case that
part of it for languages like if it's
nasty you're like I learned it I'm not
doing anything else but I don't think so
I think that his paper leans more toward
than it's a social construct like if you
work at a particular company that uses
ax you tend to use it if you work in if
you use a programming language you tend
to use the ones that you heard about
before so what for example if I recall
correctly and I'm not prepared to talk
about this paper but off the top of my
head I want to say that the most like
the strongest predictor of what language
you'll use next is the one that you use
previously so you know stuff like that
great series I guess I'm just observing
this over my career okay
COBOL became weather-wise partly because
our regime was really really horrible
because businesses said this is what you
did just to be bought IBM maybe gives
you express big numbers in the world
without floating point you can represent
accurately Thanks okay so there's some
things that really compel people
business reasons to did that okay
Pascal came along and that was really
successful because everybody is forced
to learn it wasn't successful but for a
while okay
every was forced to learn him five
people with docker in computer science
departments which are all like new in
the 80s Visual Basic came along I
remember making fun of a friend of mine
who's like a visual basic programmers
because I was like you know a Cee Cee
Lo's I kind of day and he says no what
my experience and again it's his
experience is that he was able to get
cheaper more productive guys who ran a
consulting business we can actually
produce code faster and so they have an
arguing what the people got into that
and then once they're in it yes they're
used to it they know the language we
tried to get them to go to this C sharp
and they're like what are you doing we
love
Visual Basic and then the web thing
comes there are different reasons maybe
you know why people found something you
know that became a great tool for what
they had to do then the thing becomes a
trench but I think the reasons actually
you're kind of very like that's trying
to illustrate there about why it
happened so that the saying of you were
saying about understanding kind of the
human nature aspect of how humans in our
with programming languages environs is
probably far more relevant in certain
perspectives and all the analysis of
types what languages should look like
productivity and 10% room here is a
social human factor well I don't think
necessarily that Maravich would disagree
with that like these human constructs
that's what I'm saying it's kind of
social problem right this is what I mean
by that is we're saying effectively the
same thing in very different ways but
yeah you gave communities I think for
every there are a whole bunch of
different reasons
yeah I agree and that's that's actually
what the Marrakesh type of paper shows
is that there's all it's complicated
right adoption is a complicated thing
yeah someone who has kind of two
questions that are related to each other
which is about how do you evolve so the
first question is about let's say a
language came out there's like 15
studies that show that you know the use
of mango practice for generics turns out
to be worse than if you use something
else how do you evolve that language
given the authority out there and
there's cookery than that edge and the
second thing is we have a community of
researchers who apparently and suffrage
Inc don't often do randomized controlled
trials how do you evolve them to start
doing that without saying tomorrow the
standard has changed and we're going to
reject all papers that don't do these
randomized control trials perfectly
which is the kind of thing that's
actually happening with user studies in
some of these fields like in the AAC
conference or in FSC where it's not the
incumbents if you use your studies and
all of a sudden people who are good at
evaluating user service like well that's
not done properly so I'm going to reject
the paper so there's no way to teach the
community how to do these things without
making them perfect like how do you
involve both the languages the programs
and the people over time to get to
better standards boy that's a both of
those questions are super hard so thanks
No
um let me get let me do the second one
first because I think that it's not
necessarily easier from a social
perspective but I think that you're
completely right like the implication of
the question is that you know this is
not boolean right
not only is it not the case that all
papers should be randomized control
trials that's weird that there needs to
be coherence but in addition to that you
know even people's understanding isn't
boolean you know like we don't teach how
to do this stuff in school not really at
least in computer science we don't
really teach it at conferences and you
can't fly around every conference and do
like workshops and stuff I know there's
been some I've done some but that's hard
so the question is how do you do it and
the answer is I don't know exactly I
think this is a problem that's bigger
than me
right but my suspicion is there's
probably an educational component we
should try to get it in schools more
over time I think that we should try to
get it into like conferences in terms of
like workshops to help people I think
that would be good I think that the
National Science Foundation giving money
to it meaning like they should get
communities together that are both
scientists and practitioners you know
like we need people that are in the
trenches not only to study but to give
feedback but we also need people that
understand all the data and stuff like
that in medicine they took a totally
different tact for changing it and as
they changed the law right and
specifically what happened was in the
40s doctors didn't want to use the
scientific method right because they
believed they were right and they were
trying to help their patients so
Congress changed the law they started to
say this happened really early actually
like so in 1902 they changed the law so
that if you were to give a drug yet to
say what was in it right and like that
sounds today like totally obvious but
yet this a was in it but you didn't have
to say whether it works right and then
in 1927 they got they created the FDA
and they said okay well we don't know
what the answer is or how to evaluate it
but we do know that we should check if
it kills people and sometimes it was so
the question is then how do we proceed
to like do we get communities to have
minimal policing and pop it up over time
do we do training do we do all of the
above since I'm kind of a coherence guy
I kind of take the all-of-the-above
approach but I really don't like exactly
we just said which is just like oh this
is totally imperfect we need to reject
everything like that
I think that's not so I think this is
learning right researchers learn to
maybe disagree but I don't you do but
yeah
okay so then there's the first question
which is how what do we do about
evolving the language I think this is
actually really hard and so you know I
like to solve really really easy
problems right or try to so there's been
a number of approaches I think we all
know some languages take the approach of
we're only going to add the language and
we never change anything that that came
before it and then there's the opposite
like the Python 3 to 2 debate how many
people know that I don't so it's kind of
like they changed some stuff to broke
backward compatibility and so I'll tell
you two things that we do in our lab but
we have it easy compared to all you in
my lab we developed a programming
language called poram which is only used
by about 2,500 kids but that's still a
lot of kids right all over the world and
so we make a rule we say we're gonna
break backwards-compatibility once a
year and we can do that because it's
mostly teachers when we work in
education the next generation of kids
that comes around the next year does not
care at all right because that's not the
point
but that's not fair that's not an easy
thing like if you're working on C++ then
you know you can't just say sorry we
don't have pointers anymore because
you're gonna break a little code right
I'm gonna go on a limb right so the
question is how do we do that
I mean I think again it's a multi-prong
thing like on the one hand we have to
get people to understand even what
evidence is so that they think that
maybe there's a need for that we need to
train people on what the impacts are and
go for the biggest ones but we also have
to do it in such a way that we don't
break the things that will cause the
most harm to the community like turning
off pointers all of a sudden stuff like
that or that's just an example but you
get the idea right features that are
fundamentally game-breaking on the other
hand it could be that for some of these
languages over like a twenty thirty
fifty or a hundred year period that we
can start to change a few things here
and a few things there on a schedule
where everybody knows it's coming
everybody knows what the plan is and
everybody knows what the evidence is and
can try to refute it right they can say
C++ on this date is changing to this and
all the compilers that people do and if
you don't
like that here's the study methodologies
the data for them and if you don't like
it you can try to refute it but you know
this is Andy's pipe dream world where
that really did they try that because I
said I don't know if that's quite fair
because y2k was a problem that was
deeply rooted but like suppose we said
you know it depends on that the amount
of change that you're requesting code
crap about any any subtraction or change
right so yeah so subtractions would need
more evidence in addition you know stuff
you'd have to be sensible right so know
how many versions of C++ implementations
there are I don't you not parse by and
every compiler like literally oranges
and that didn't involve that many
official versions of C++ and yet there
are still so many that can't read like
certainly lots of code for Microsoft
can't be read by Microsoft compilers yes
that's true but I just got an
interesting secret about visuals see it
and it was this yeah nice nothing about
who was checking into our tree and doing
some stock and you know signing bugs not
long ago I discovered that site they've
covered changed everything that res this
one guy was checking in all these
changes to virtually everything
throughout the entire tree turned out to
be the guide for visual studio this job
of was is to make our code work with the
latest compiler Thanks yeah so I don't I
don't think there's it's it's very
agreeable and kind of obvious the way
you've laid it out that we should have
more control studies and better evidence
for these things I wanted to ask the
example and almost all of your the
running theme all of your example system
this idea of productivity and I'm
wondering if that's like is that an
innocent choice of metric like why is
that the thing
we're looking to optimize or study oh no
that's a great question actually so it's
not the only thing that has been studied
in the literature but it's one that is
often mentioned in terms of time because
time costs that's usually why people
study it you know like for example if
you know that you're gonna reduce the
time to fix compiler error so oh here's
an example there's a natural study not a
controlled study but it's really
excellent natural study by Brett Becker
this guy in the UK that is kind of a
young dude that maybe isn't what that
well known it but shitty because his
work is fantastic
um and Brett did this study on like
changing compiler errors to be sort of
like more friendly to people right and
he did just really obvious things like
instead of saying like eat my face it
would say hey there's an error on line 5
you know I mean it's a terrible example
I don't know why I said that
but just just bear with it the point is
he would take messages that were perhaps
esoteric and he would do his best right
he didn't have a methodology for knowing
what to change in them but he wanted to
try and he found some percentage
increase I mean decrease in the amount
of time to remove errors now in that
case it's time so you could call it
productivity but he was thinking that
that if that was a developer that would
cost right so that cost money but on the
other hand like that's obviously not the
only thing you care about there's you
can analyze comprehension metrics you
could analyze accuracy so sometimes we
do accuracy studies for syntax like how
accurately can they put in the syntax
stuff like that and I think all those
things should be studied again its
coherence right like you want all these
studies to know the totality of evidence
but time is a common theme for that
reason so yeah but now is vulnerability
the weds the vulnerabilities in software
nobody's new software vulnerabilities
every day you read the paper the
tremendous cost is society and companies
and everything else but of all their
abilities
oh yeah that's granted yeah I've heard
that before I give it
ha cat seeing me once and someone
mention that and I think it's spot-on
right like why not why not try to figure
out you know can we reduce that a little
bit too that's great yeah that's what I
love about this coherence ideas like it
doesn't say you know this person's right
that person is wrong whatever it says
like why don't we just look at it all
and then try to reverse-engineer it
natural studies are good control studies
have a different purpose and they work
at different scales for good reason
right there they let you try crazy
things right anyway
other questions all right well thank you
very much for coming I appreciate it
[Applause]